[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN FRIED: I'm Ben Fried.
I'm Google's CIO.
I'm one of the site
leads here in New York.
And I am thrilled and
overwhelmed to welcome
the playwright and cast of
"To Kill a Mockingbird."
[APPLAUSE]
It seems redundant to have
to introduce the crew here,
but I will, Celia Keenan-Bolger,
Gideon Glick, Aaron Sorkin,
Jeff Daniels, Gbena
Akinnagbe-- agbe?
I'm trying.
GBENGA AKINNAGBE:
I know you are.
BEN FRIED: The glottal G. I'm
sorry, not enough practice.
And I have, actually,
a summary that I
was given from the
publicists of the play.
Do I need to summarize
"To Kill a Mockingbird"
for this audience?
No?
It seems like there's
better uses of our time.
So anyway, so welcome.
We're really, really, really
excited to have you all here.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
And I guess it's a big week.
Nine Tony Awards?
Congratulations.
Nine Tony Award nominations.
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER:
Nominations.
BEN FRIED: I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Nine Tony Award nomin--
I hope I didn't jinx it.
Nine Tony Award nominations,
including to Jeff,
to Gideon, and to Cecilia.
Well done.
And you set a record for, is it
highest grossing American play?
GIDEON GLICK: We
all look to Aaron.
AARON SORKIN: We're actually
the first, second, third,
and fourth highest grossing.
We broke our own
record four times.
BEN FRIED: Congratulations.
I guess it was
announced, in 2016,
that Aaron was going to be
adapting the novel into a play?
I guess to start, Aaron,
what led you there?
What led you to the project?
Where did your
interest come from?
AARON SORKIN: The producer Scott
Rudin, with whom I've worked
a number of times, called me.
He said, I have something very
exciting to talk to you about.
After trying for a long time,
I've acquired the stage rights
for "To Kill a Mockingbird."
And he asked me
to write the play.
And honestly, I felt
like it was a suicide
mission, but the
idea of doing a play,
and I just loved doing plays.
And he was dangling the
director, Bartlett Sher,
in front of me, and the
chance to work with him.
We knew in that first phone
call that it was going
to be Jeff playing Atticus.
So the chance to work with Jeff
again was what made me say,
go ahead on the suicide mission.
And I wrote a first
draft that was terrible.
Really, the best you
could say about it
was that it was harmless,
which is probably
the worst thing you could say
about a play, and particularly
"To Kill a Mockingbird."
I was very gentle.
I didn't want to ruin
anyone's childhood.
And so I just I took the most
necessary scenes in the book
and I stood them up.
And the whole
thing ended up just
reading like a greatest hits
album done by a cover band.
There was really just
nothing to it at all.
And Scott Rudin, the producer,
told me so, and he was right.
But the big thing
he said, and this
was my big motivation going
forward, was simply this--
and I assume I'm talking
to a roomful of people
who have read the book,
seen the movie, or both.
Here's what he said.
Atticus can't be Atticus from
the beginning of the play
to the end of the play.
He has to change.
He has to be put through
something and he has to change.
I thought, of course.
I mean, a protagonist
has to have a flaw,
has to be put through
something, and has to change.
And flying home--
I live most of the
time in Los Angeles--
I just kept wondering, how
did Harper Lee get away
with an Atticus in the
novel that didn't change,
that was the same at the
beginning of the novel
as he was at the end.
How did Horton Foote,
who wrote the screenplay,
get away with an
Atticus who was the same
at the end of the movie as
he was at the beginning?
And the answer is that
Atticus is not the protagonist
in the book or in the movie.
Scout is.
She changes.
She loses some of her
innocence and her flaws,
that she's young.
And I wanted to keep
Scout and Dill and Jem,
who was played by Will Pullen.
And I wanted to keep
them as protagonists.
I wanted them to
change, but I wanted
to move Atticus front and
center, make him a protagonist,
put him through something.
That was the impetus for
the next draft that I did.
And I did that draft over the
course of about six months,
sent it to Scott.
And the way I knew that he
liked it wasn't from him
calling me and telling me.
It was that six days later,
in the Sunday "New York Times"
Arts and Leisure section
in the fall preview,
he took out a
two-page ad saying,
"To Kill a Mockingbird," a
new play by Aaron Sorkin,
opening Christmas 2018.
There we were.
BEN FRIED: So he's
a man of action.
So a question for all of you.
You had, I read, something like
18 months of rehearsal time.
How did the play develop
over the rehearsal?
Did it develop over the
course of the performance?
I say that having seen
you all perform it
on the first week of
November, and then
having seen it again
the week before last.
So it seems like things happen
you learned along the way.
What was that like?
What happened?
How did you develop
your characters?
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER:
I would say one
of the great joys
of this process
was watching Aaron, who I
have admired for a very, very
long time, write and
rewrite this play,
and understand what
needed to be pulled out,
where he needed to cut the fat.
So a lot of the
beginning process
was that, was us
sitting around a table,
reading it, Aaron going away,
coming back with a new draft,
going away.
I mean, and that happened.
We did two readings.
We did some workshops.
And during one of the workshops,
Bart Sher, the director,
he was like, this
section seems hard,
and so let's try to stage it.
And I had never worked on
something-- usually when
you began a theatrical
process, there's
like the set model and
the costume renderings.
And they're like, this is
what it's going to look like.
And in this version,
none of that existed.
So the designers were coming.
They were watching how we
were trying to build the play.
And it was truly one of the
most collaborative experiences
I've ever had, because then
we started putting things up
on their feet.
And Miriam, the set
designer, was like,
maybe we could have
the jury over here
and the porch could
come in from the sides.
And that's now what
our set looks like.
So we went through all of
that developmental process
of trying to figure out how we
were going to tell the story.
And then we had six
weeks of rehearsal
and six weeks of previews.
And the previews were
really when shit got crazy,
because Aaron just kept at it.
And I remember the
second week of previews,
I was like, it's ready.
We're ready.
And then six weeks
later, I was like,
here we are, still putting
in new Aaron Sorkin dialogue
every single night.
And we would rehearse a
version during the day.
We would put it on its feet.
And then at the end of the day,
we would say, it's no good.
We're not going to do that.
We're going to do the
version we did last night.
And then we would come in the
next day with something new,
and they would say, it's really
good, but it's not ready.
So you do the version that
you did last night tonight,
but tomorrow, we'll
put the version
in that you rehearsed today.
So your brain is
just doing a lot
of mental Sorkinese gymnastics.
I mean, it's exhilarating.
And also, you're like, these
people did pay a lot of money
to be here so don't
ruin it for them.
So that's sort of a snapshot
of what that looked like.
BEN FRIED: Wow.
Anything you want to add?
GBENGA AKINNAGBE:
That's what happened.
BEN FRIED: Wow.
So as a, perhaps,
naive audience member,
I had a question that has to
do with the performance, which
is to people who
are literate in TV
and in movies, the fractured
narrative that you have,
the intersperses,
the trial and segment
with the different,
more linear narrative,
it's very natural to watch.
But I realized the second time
I saw the play, that can't
be the natural to perform.
And that was before I even knew
that you were switching it up
and you were jumping
backwards and forwards across
takes on the performance.
Is that kind of
fractured timeline
hard to work through as actors?
Is there lots of
switching, and you
have to keep track of tense,
and am I an adult now,
am I a child?
JEFF DANIELS: We
heard that a lot.
AARON SORKIN: Yeah, you didn't
like those conversations.
You're like, enough.
Yeah.
I think it's still
even in process.
And that's kind of the
beautiful thing about theater,
is that sometimes we were sure
we were adults in one scene,
or in one narration, and now
we're just not, and vice versa.
And I'll say it is
challenging to have--
sometimes you have
an emotional response
to something that happened
maybe four minutes ago,
but now there's a narration,
and in the middle of it,
and then it comes back, and now
we're at the end of that scene
again.
So then you have to be
emotionally present.
So it's like a
weird juggling act
that you're doing, where
you're trying to ride the wave,
but also kind of sit in the
emotion at the same time.
AARON SORKIN: And for
them, in addition to
the juggling act of, am I an
adult, am I a kid right now?
They also talk to the audience.
BEN FRIED: Yeah, they
break [INAUDIBLE]
AARON SORKIN: And it's more
than just exposition, especially
with Scout.
She's trying to puzzle
something through with them.
Once that happens, then the
logic, their logic on stage--
you have to ask yourself, if
I'm talking to the audience,
aren't I in the Shubert
theater right now,
but I'm also in Macomb?
And I might be a little
kid, I might be an adult.
And we never actually say
how old the adult version
of the person is.
So it is a lot for the actors
to get their arms around.
Less gifted actors
than Celia and Gideon
and Will Pullen I
think either would just
become frustrated
with it or would not
bother to deal with it, but it
would just kind of be general.
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER: I also
think so many things in life
that that problem,
which presented itself
during the rehearsal, which
was the thorniest and the most
frustrating in the running of it
and the doing of it every night
has become the most gratifying.
And because we had a good
director and a good writer,
who didn't feel the need to
give absolutes about the answers
that we were in pursuit
of, it stayed open-ended.
But we had a foundation
that was strong enough
that now, the doing of
it, because it isn't
so clear or linear,
I think is actually
more interesting to do it, if
you have to do it eight times
a week.
GIDEON GLICK: For a year.
BEN FRIED: Well, as
an audience member,
I can get that because you
never consciously ask yourself,
wait, what point is it in this
character's life right now?
You just absorb
it and you feel it
without it having to have
been explained to you,
even as it changes.
AARON SORKIN: That's
helped right away.
It's more than helped.
It's set up, right away,
by Bart Sher, our director,
and the design of the play,
Miriam boother, our set
designer, Jennifer Tipton,
the lighting designer, and Ann
Roth, the costume designer.
And when the curtain
goes up on the play--
it's actually not
a curtain at all.
It's a wall that kind of
resembles the side of a barn,
but weathered.
It hasn't been tended
to in 60 years or so.
When that goes up, if you
know "To Kill a Mockingbird"--
most people who are
sitting in the theater do--
you're expecting to
see a front porch,
or a bucolic rural
street, maybe an oak tree.
You don't see any of that.
You see something that
resembles the place where
they shot the Childish Gambino
video, This is America.
It's an abandoned warehouse.
It's a warehouse
structure, but again, it
hasn't been tended to,
visited in a long time.
There are broken windows
and paint is peeling.
And scout is standing on
stage, along with a newspaper.
And the first line
of the play is,
something didn't make sense.
And so what happens
is, because of that,
at least the effect is,
we're revisiting something,
this story that hasn't been
revisited in a long time,
and we're going to ask
questions about it.
And I guess that
was a very long way
of saying because
we don't start off
the play in a literal space.
They bring in the
literal space when
they start talking about what
the court room looked like.
Then characters start coming on.
They bring in the literal space.
I couldn't tell
them where exactly
they are when the play begins,
and I'm not sure I'd want to.
BEN FRIED: Wow.
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER:
You said it once.
AARON SORKIN: I did, but
you didn't like the answer.
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER: I loved it.
It was like a beautiful--
what did you say?
AARON SORKIN: Oh, really?
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER: It was
like space or something.
AARON SORKIN: I
wouldn't have said that.
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER: No.
AARON SORKIN: I'm glad
that it was helpful.
I wish I could remember it now.
GIDEON GLICK: I said
the astral plane,
the time-space continuum.
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER: Continuum,
that's what you said.
BEN FRIED: OK.
All right.
Slight shift of subject.
Jeff, moving on.
AARON SORKIN: [INAUDIBLE]
GIDEON GLICK: We're in
the time-space continuum.
BEN FRIED: Jeff, a
question for you.
JEFF DANIELS: Continuum?
BEN FRIED: Someone described
Atticus Finch to me
as the patron saint
of fatherhood,
at least as captured by Horton
Foote and by Harper Lee.
And that seems like kind
of a heavy burden to carry.
Did the new take on the
character, and this idea
of a journey and development,
make the approach
easier, or less daunting,
or maybe it wasn't daunting?
JEFF DANIELS: When
Aaron said, do
you want to do Atticus,
it was, of course.
Yeah, I wanted challenges
ever since "The Newsroom,"
and some other
things before that.
"God of Carnage."
I've just been going, if
you aren't challenged,
then don't do this anymore.
And this is the
ultimate challenge.
I mean, you're taking on
not only Gregory Peck,
but you're taking on
paternal saint of whatever,
fatherhood, whatever that
means to people, whoever
Atticus is in their own minds
having read the book 27 times.
You're taking on all that.
BEN FRIED: Yeah.
JEFF DANIELS: And
I didn't blink.
I just didn't.
Whether it's naive, or
whether it's just innocence,
or whether-- you know what?
I mean this is Google,
you hit Delete.
You hit Delete on
all of that stuff,
because it isn't the
Horton Foote script
and it isn't the book.
It's a play based
on the book and it's
what Aaron is doing with it.
And I know how to
get around Aaron
and how to execute Aaron
in a way that he can--
and to be in a rehearsal
room with where
he gets the time to rewrite.
That was the battle
on "Newsroom."
BEN FRIED: Really?
JEFF DANIELS: Was that he had
to turn it in Thursday at noon.
That's it.
And every two weeks,
this guy would come out
with 75 pages of, how
the hell does he do it?
BEN FRIED: Wow.
JEFF DANIELS: But to
watch him have the time
to really do what playwrights
do, which is what he is,
it was thrilling.
If we're going to climb Mount
Everest, and Harper Lee,
and the Pulitzer,
and Gregory Peck,
and all the people who
loved the book, then
who do you want in your foxhole?
And you start
there, as an actor.
You've got Scott Rudin, who
is the producer you need
for something like this and
the journey this one took,
Bart Sher, who directs
operas in his spare time.
And then you get into
that first reading
and you get these people.
I mean these people were all
here in that first reading,
I think, way back in October.
Other people kind of came and
went, but not these three.
And Will Pullen also.
We got a core group that
can now take this thing on
and now it's pedal to the metal
and fifth gear, and all that.
Now, let's go.
Who's with me?
Who's going?
And these people were, from day
1, let's go, and didn't blink.
And that was thrilling.
We may have failed.
Oh my god, yeah.
This had failure
written all over it.
He does not measure up to
Mr. Peck, I'm so sorry.
What he does to the
book is criminal.
And why do you have three
adults playing children?
Going into that first preview,
that was all on the table,
and it all worked,
and that's what
makes it even more gratifying.
BEN FRIED: It really did.
Hey, Gbenga, a question for you?
So first of all, this
is your Broadway debut?
Do I have that right?
GBENGA AKINNAGBE: Yes.
BEN FRIED: Well done.
Well done, sir.
[APPLAUSE]
GBENGA AKINNAGBE: It's
all downhill from here.
BEN FRIED: So you wrote
this really powerful piece
for "The Washington Post"
some time ago about how
the show has affected you.
And I was struck
by the way that you
speak about how far we have
not come for African Americans,
for black Americans, about the
feelings of safety that you
don't have, about how
the experience of being
Tom Robinson every night fills
your life as you go through it.
What more can you tell us,
can you tell this audience,
about the process?
How do you feel, Tom?
How do you let that go
at the end of the day?
GBENGA AKINNAGBE: Brownies
and ice cream every night,
every single night.
I'm not exaggerating.
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER:
He's not kidding.
GBENGA AKINNAGBE:
I'm not kidding.
What she described, as far
as the development process
and the rehearsal process,
was quite accurate.
For me, for a lot of us,
this was the most organic
coming to being of a piece
that we've ever been a part of,
at least for me.
Having been able to
workshop it with them
for over a year, and then the
rehearsal period, and then
the previews, which went twice
as long as normal previews go,
so it really baked into us.
But sitting around
the table and having
these minds and these
artists and Aaron really
do this work in front of us,
it felt like a safe space
where we could create
whatever this was going to be.
And it helped me open up
and let go into this world
that we were creating,
which was not
and is not safe for
black people, and open up
and live that.
And it was funny because when
we left the basement of Lincoln
Center, I was reluctant.
I was like, why do
we have to move?
Let's continue to do
this for us every day.
It was very gratifying.
It was time for us to get the
hell out of that basement.
But I had forgotten that it
was ever going to be part of,
or disassociated
from the fact that it
was going to be on
a Broadway stage,
that it was based on a book
that so many Americans felt
ownership of.
It was just us doing it
for us in that basement
and just working on it,
working on it, which I loved.
So that helped, when it was
time to go to that stage
and just do what we have--
like everything that Jeff said.
We had the band
together and like,
all right, you
work on that base.
You tune the amp.
So we got together and just do
what we started to learn to do
and what we loved doing.
And then when we started to
do it in front of audiences--
and you could feel,
especially the first few weeks
that audiences showed
up, just daring
us to screw up their childhood.
I wish you would.
BEN FRIED: Really?
GBENGA AKINNAGBE:
I wish you would.
And then that started to
change when they felt like they
could trust us with it.
But to answer your question,
having that process,
leading up to it,
is what enabled
me to be able to do this there.
Now, you mentioned
"The Washington Post"
piece that came out this
weekend, or this past weekend.
I wrote that because
what I didn't realize
was how doing that,
playing this role,
in front of so many people,
so many white people
with disposable income,
how that would affect me.
I did not see that
coming, and every night.
Can we curse?
It started to fuck with me.
BEN FRIED: Yeah, please, please.
GBENGA AKINNAGBE:
So I just needed
to get it out and
express it somehow,
and I was fortunate enough to be
able find a platform, a venue,
to do so.
But it's still
something I process.
And taking into
everything that we
worked on into that
rehearsal space, when
it came to race and the use of
the n-word and class and so on,
and understanding it
intellectually and creatively--
but when I got out there
on the stage, the creative
and the intellectual
was right out the door.
Because I'm looking
at audience full
of people who, most likely,
share the same politics
as I do, but are definitely
benefactors of this
really fucked up
system, and I'm playing
this role in front of them.
So it was just
like, this is crazy.
But it's a beautiful
opportunity as well.
Did I answer it?
BEN FRIED: Yes.
AARON SORKIN: I really
recommend the piece.
Well, it's
magnificently written.
I found it fascinating.
And it's online, if you
know how to google it.
BEN FRIED: We can provide
some help for that.
So on the subject of process and
kind of touching on differences
with the source material a
little bit, it was hard for me
not to read recent events
into the play, [INAUDIBLE]
It was hard for me
not to hear echoes
of Ferguson and
Charlottesville and the murder
of James Byrd, who's
killer was executed,
back at the end of April.
It was hard.
There seemed to be explicit
references to the language,
like I said, the language
of Charlottesville
and the events of Ferguson
and the murder of James Byrd.
Am I just hallucinating?
Was there intent to bring that?
AARON SORKIN: You're
not hallucinating.
After that first draft,
which I just think scared me
into taking a chance,
doing something better,
one of the things that
I sort of vowed to do
was that I wasn't
going to pretend that I
was writing the play in 1960.
I'm writing it now.
Things have happened since then.
One of the things
that happened--
I had mentioned
before that Atticus,
now as the central
protagonist, needed a flaw.
In the book, in the movie,
he doesn't have one.
He's a guy carved out of marble.
He's the guy who
has all the answers.
And in the play, I wanted
him wrestling with questions.
So in searching for a
flaw, I thought, boy,
if I wasn't going to get killed
before giving Atticus a flaw,
what am I going to do,
turn him from a bad lawyer
into a good lawyer, a bad father
into a good father, a racist
then to someone who believes
in equality and justice?
I realized I didn't
have to give him a flaw.
He already had one.
It's just that when I
learned the book, at least
in the 7th, 8th, and 9th grade,
and I'll bet people still
today, that it's regarded
as a virtue, which
is that Atticus believes that
there is goodness in everyone.
Atticus, throughout the
book, excuses racism.
He excuses Bob Ewell as someone
who just lost his WPA job.
So please, you gotta understand.
Excuses Mrs. DuBose as someone
who recently stopped taking
her medication, her morphine.
So you got to understand,
he excuses the whole town
of Macomb.
Things happen slower here.
This is the deep south.
Don't worry, they'll catch up.
There's goodness
in everyone, all
you have to do is crawl around
inside their skin for a while.
There's goodness in everyone.
And while I was dealing with
this as something, which now,
a long time after I'd read
the book for the first time
and sort of formed my
thoughts about Atticus--
who'd always been
a hero, still is--
suddenly, this was like
a pebble in my shoe.
I wasn't crazy about
this part of Atticus.
Right smack in the
middle of thinking
that, Donald Trump said there
are fine people on both sides,
and that's what it is.
Atticus is going to have
to, by the end of the play,
understand that there aren't
fine people on both sides,
and that his other mantra
throughout the play, which is I
know these people.
My family, we've lived in this
and make them for generations.
I know these people.
They are friends and neighbors.
Sure, some of them are
still stuck in the old ways,
but none of them are
so far gone that they
would send an obviously innocent
man to the electric chair.
He's wrong about that, too.
And I felt like that
feels like today, too,
that a lot of us for the last
few years, no matter where you
are on the ideological spectrum,
a lot of us have felt like,
God, I thought I knew my
neighbors in this country.
I thought I knew everybody else.
I didn't, personally.
And a lot of people here
will roll their eyes
and say, welcome to reality.
I had no idea the
level of misogyny,
until Hillary Clinton
ran for president.
It's not sexism,
straight up misogyny.
Anyway, you asked,
did the current--
BEN FRIED: You
exceeded [INAUDIBLE]
AARON SORKIN: You
have to understand.
Growing up in my
family, anybody who
used one word when they
could have used 10 just
wasn't trying hard enough.
So did what's going
on now, yes, it just
made its way into the
air supply of the play,
into the water supply.
BEN FRIED: So it's
something you mentioned,
it's Calpurnia who challenges
Atticus, especially about
Mrs. DuBose at [INAUDIBLE].
She was a racist
before she got sick.
AARON SORKIN: She was a negro
hating sack of dirt before.
It was medicinally enhanced.
JEFF DANIELS: Nice.
BEN FRIED: Yeah, there's a
reason you're the writer.
So the two primary African
American characters
have an agency and
an independence
that isn't present in the
prior material at all.
It's amazing.
Tom is, if you'll go back
to the source material,
is very lightly
sketched, if at all.
Maybe he's kind of
a Christlike figure,
but we get no insight into him.
And as an audience
member, the thing
that I saw that
was so impressive
was a man finding agency
in a situation where
his victimhood is
assured, where he
has no actual, for good
reason, has no expectation
of just treatment.
But he finds a path to
agency and expression
that wasn't present
in the prior world.
And in a different
way, Cal expresses
a voice, a grounded voice,
that we don't see elsewhere.
How did that, really,
for the two of you,
how did you think about bringing
those ideas into the play?
And I think it's a big change
that really adds to the power,
measurably.
AARON SORKIN: Yes,
you're right there.
There are two, only two,
significant African American
characters in the book,
Calpurnia, Tom Robinson.
And in a play about racial
friction in the Jim Crow South,
neither of the two African
American characters
really have anything
to say about it.
And you're right, they
don't have agency.
I always want to tread
lightly here because I do not
want to give the impression
that in writing the play,
I set out to correct
mistakes that I perceived
Harper Lee made.
It's not it at all.
It's simply, again,
that I wasn't
going to pretend I was
writing the play in 1960,
and I wasn't going to try to
do a Harper Lee impersonation.
So I was just following my
own instincts a little bit.
I thought, A, you simply can't
use African American characters
only as atmosphere,
and B, what a waste.
These are two characters that
can be sensational characters
and add to kind of the
conversation of the play.
So with Tom, Tom gets
to make decisions now.
He makes the
decision now-- and I
don't want to give
away too many spoilers
if you haven't seen the play.
He makes the decision
to go to court.
When this play begins now, he
has a different lawyer, not
Atticus, and he's taken
a plea bargain 18 years.
Then he makes a
different decision
after talking to Atticus.
All of these decisions are based
on what is best for his kids.
He's trying to
reason through that.
And then in the second act,
he makes another decision
that I won't articulate.
It is a spoiler.
And it's a grave decision.
I don't mean that
in the pun sense,
like Shakespeare would use it.
It is a decision
that makes him dead.
He doesn't know that.
It's a serious decision
is what I mean to say.
He gets a chance to
grab at this opportunity
to just take control
over his life
for one moment in the
midst of this trial,
where he's being accused of
being sexually monstrous,
where he's being
called the n word,
where he's being called boy.
It's harsh.
Plus, he's been in jail
seven months already.
So he gets to do more than
just plead for his life.
We get to see some
in our life there.
GBENGA AKINNAGBE: But one of
the things that attracted me
to this project, aside
from the people involved,
is the perspective
of the creative team,
that they wanted to
eliminate as many instances
of this white savior motif that
is throughout literature, even
with great writers.
I mean, I'll say
it, that Harper Lee
wouldn't be the first
amazing writer who
was blind to the full lives
of minorities, of women,
of the people.
So it might not be
safe for other folks.
I don't want anyone to get
in trouble, but it's true.
And this creative team
wanted to address that,
and so that was
attractive to me.
And one of the immediate
ways to do that
is to give these two characters,
whose lives are affected,
one to the point where
his life comes to an end,
by what goes on.
And I love the book,
but it was problematic.
You have this
thing that happened
to this black person that
affects entire black community,
and it's seen through the
eyes of this white family,
in this white little girl.
Beautifully told, but to
me, that's problematic.
And those are some
of the things,
I think, the playwright wanted
to address and bring to life
and kind of fill
out on stage, and I
think he accomplished that.
BEN FRIED: I read somewhere
that all Harper Lee's friendship
with Truman Capote
influenced the construction
of the character of Dill.
I was wondering, you
worked through rehearsal
to create that character.
Was that an idea in
your mind somehow,
that the fact that Capote--
and I guess it is rumored
that he helped edit the book,
or something like--
GIDEON GLICK: Capote's his
life was infused into the text.
I mean, his back story
was added in a small dose.
And it is known that Dill
was based off Capote.
And so yes, that was a gigantic
part of the inspiration
for this Dill.
But what I also realized
was that this piece,
it's about race, but
it's also about identity.
It's about intersectionality.
It's not just one thing.
And that was something that
blew my mind, in that you
have a protagonist who
kind of feels like a boy.
She's a tomboy, and her best
friend is this queer boy.
And this is a book that
is taught ad nauseum,
and we don't talk about that.
And so I was really excited
about exploding that and making
sure that this is going to
be talked about from now on.
BEN FRIED: And it
is masterfully,
masterfully handle.
Because it is, again,
one of these things
that appears so
natural on the stage,
that you just see
it in front of you
without having to
think about it.
GIDEON GLICK: Well, thank you.
That's his doing, too.
AARON SORKIN: You know what?
I appreciate that,
but this whole thing
has been a triumph
of collaboration.
But during that process that
Celia was talking about,
the labs, the six-week rehearsal
period on the previews,
with Gideon and Dill,
I found, oftentimes,
we were following each other.
You'd do something, and Bart
and I, standing back, would say,
that's great.
I get that.
Let's codify that.
Let's make more of that.
So I was following Gideon a lot.
BEN FRIED: So why
don't we start here.
Ma'am?
AUDIENCE: Hi Thank you
all for being here today.
I actually had a question
for Gideon and Celia.
You talked a little
bit about how
you're deciding, or figuring
out, when you were an adult
and when you were a child.
But I was wondering, once
you had figured that out,
how did you try to inhabit the
characters differently and take
that knowledge into
your performance
and try to make those
characters slightly different?
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER: I think it
was sort of twofold, that there
was the physicality of kids.
There is this really
amazing interview
with Harper Lee, where she
was talking about growing up
in Monroeville.
And she just said,
we had nothing.
There was nothing
there for us to do.
So our imaginations
were the only escape
from the monotony of a summer
in Monroeville, Alabama.
And that, somehow, just
planted a strong seed in me.
Like, what do you do if you're
a kid and there's nothing to do?
And so a lot of what we ended
up building physically had to do
with, what kind of
games do kids play?
Just how do you use the world
around you, an empty space,
like a stage, that
has nothing, and try
to create the life, the
physical life, of a kid.
And so that was
a big part of it.
I think, vocally, this in and
out of (HIGH-PITCHED ACCENT)
when I'm Scout, who's eight,
it's pitched way up here.
And then (LOW-PITCHED ACCENT)
when I'm talking a little bit
older, I drop into
a lower register.
That's just a stupid theater
trick that is as old as time.
But there is that as well.
And then I think,
honestly, the writing took
care of so much of who we were
and how these little creatures
went through the play,
that there was so much that
was there that I felt like
we could always do less,
particularly when we
were playing the kids,
that I would have these
ideas and Bart was like,
don't do that.
No problem.
But that the writing
was good enough
and it supported us, both
as children and as adults,
that in doubt, do us.
GIDEON GLICK: I can't
improve on that.
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER: Thank you.
AARON SORKIN: I'm sorry.
I just think Celia really soft
sold what these guys are doing.
It's not just about
dropping down a register.
They are doing something,
and have been doing it
since early in rehearsals, but
it just got better and better.
They're doing something
much more nuanced than that
and it's, to me, a magic trick.
It's the slightest
adjustments in their posture,
slightest adjustment
in their voice,
but just also a slight
adjustment in their attitude
going back and
forth, which they are
doing not just
throughout the play,
but they'll do it throughout
a scene, inside of a scene.
And it's not at all jarring.
I have never been a
particular fan of grown men
and women acting like children.
I didn't like Jerry
Lewis or Lou Costello.
It just creeps me
out a little bit.
But this isn't at all like that.
And so I just
think that you made
it sound much easier
than it actually is.
AUDIENCE: My question is,
whenever you adapt something,
people forget it's
a different medium
and it's a different time.
And maybe it's just me and
watching too many YouTube
previews, but people get
very aggressive to take
the originalistic gospel
and everything that
deviates as like sacreligious.
Where do you take the
courage to address changes?
And especially to
the actors, how
do you deal with
the backlash you
get and the critiques,
if people say, yeah,
you ruined my
childhood, or whatever.
GIDEON GLICK: I think
it was definitely
terrifying in the beginning.
And it was definitely
terrifying, conceptually,
for an adult to play a child.
That's off-putting.
But I will say, I
think what's kind of
remarkable is that because
the medium is different,
we get to do whatever we want.
So it is a theatrical piece.
And so in a strange
way, having, let's just
say adults playing children,
the audience is sitting there
and they go, oh, this
is not what I know.
This is not the movie.
This is not the book.
This is a theater
piece that can only be
seen right now on this stage.
And in a strange way,
what I was most afraid of
is actually what
freed us all up.
BEN FRIED: Can I ask a quick
follow-up question on that.
What do you hear
from audiences--
One of the amazing
things about Broadway,
you leave the stage
door and there's
a bunch of people
waiting to talk to you.
What did you hear
from those audiences?
GIDEON GLICK: A lot of
people go, oh man, I
came in really not
looking like this,
and really not looking like
those [? white ?] kids.
But I say that was
what I find remarkable
is that the cult of
"Mockingbird" is big.
And we're seeing a
lot of people who've
never seen a play
before, and that's really
the kind of the most remarkable
thing at the stage door.
This is the first
play they ever saw.
And yeah, it's just been
a remarkable experience.
AARON SORKIN: In New York
City, a public school student
can see the play for $10.
And so we've been doing
matinees that are entirely
filled with students.
And as Gideon said,
for a lot of them,
it's their first time at a play.
They respond differently than a
typical Broadway audience does,
but they are incredibly
enthusiastic and vocal
about it.
BEN FRIED: I mean,
they're not jaded, right?
AARON SORKIN: No.
When they like something,
they'll say something funny
and they'll laugh at it.
And then they'll turn to the
person next to them and kind of
enjoy it all over again.
And then they'll all
quiet each other down
because they'll realize
the play is continuing.
No one hit pause.
And so they're kind of
learning how to watch a play.
They're having a
great experience,
on top of which, I
think, that there
are kids leaving the theater
who it never occurred
to them before that they
might like doing what
Gbenga and Gideon and Celia do.
And that they might
be good at it,
it just never occurred
to them to try it.
And I like to think
that, once in a while,
there's somebody who leaves
the theater thinking that they
might like doing what
I do and it never
occurred to them to do that.
So anyway, if you
couldn't guess,
I'm proud of those $10
public school matinees.
AUDIENCE: Thank you all
so much for being here.
My question is for Aaron.
One of my favorite things
you've ever written
was the open letter to your
daughters the morning--
AARON SORKIN: Oh, gee, thanks.
AUDIENCE: --after Donald
Trump was elected.
I was in this
office, at my desk,
shaking, holding back tears,
trying to stay professional,
trying to figure everything out.
And there was a part of that
open letter that really got me,
where you said, well,
what are we going to do?
We'll fucking fight.
We'll stand up.
We'll roll up our sleeves
because America did not stop
becoming America overnight.
And I'm wondering, when
in retelling this story
and sharing it with
so many audiences,
in America and globally,
how much of this
encompasses that fight
you're talking about.
AARON SORKIN: That's
a great question.
First of all, thanks very much.
When I wrote it, it
wasn't an open letter.
On election night
2016, I was in Toronto.
I was about to start
shooting a movie the next day
and I wasn't home.
But I was talking to
my daughter all night
as states started
turning red and people
started getting nervous.
She was genuinely upset
when this happened.
And I was saying
on the one hand,
I was really proud
that she'd become
engaged in something like this.
But I saw how upset she was.
And like a lot of people, I had
been telling her for a year,
for two years, please,
there's no way.
It's never going to happen.
So when you're a father and
you break that kind of promise,
it's tough.
I wrote the email to her early
in the morning East Coast time.
And a couple of hours later,
a woman from vanityfair.com
got in touch with me somehow.
I guess my daughter's mom
had maybe sent it to her.
So that's how that happened.
But yes.
I could've been a lot
shorter by saying, yes.
This is a part of that.
I enjoy writing romantically
and idealistically.
And Scout's repetition
of All Rise,
and particularly at the end,
is meant as a call to action.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
AARON SORKIN: Thank you.
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER:
Can I also just say
that part of what has been so
special about this experience
is that I think there aren't
that many spaces where we get
to come together and
process these big questions
about our country and
where we have been
and where we are going.
Church, I suppose.
And Aaron gave a
speech this morning
about cathedrals and theaters,
that I was like, yes,
that is what you're doing.
But that, in fact,
to come and see
a play where there is a real
transaction between the people
on stage and the
people in the audience,
a play does not exist
without the audience.
A movie or a
television show does.
And to get to, during this
time, have a real conversation
and to create a space
for all of us to come
and be together with
1,400 other people
and process these big questions
about our country, it feels--
whatever you think
about the play,
you can think about the play,
but that act of coming together
is so deeply important
and so moving,
to me, to get to do every night.
GBENGA AKINNAGBE: It's a gift.
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER: It is.
BEN FRIED: I agree.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So thank you for being
here and for making
some of my favorite things
ever on TV, on stage.
And my question for Celia,
because we talked a lot about--
you talked about playing a
child in this particular show.
But I've seen you play
a child on stage before.
I saw you in "Peter
and the Star Catcher,"
and I listened to
"Spelling Bee" often,
especially when I need to cry
a little bit, like good cry.
I wanted to know if
this is a coincidence,
or if it's something
you're drawn to,
or if you see Molly and
Scout and [INAUDIBLE] three
different beings, and just
they happen to be children.
CELIA KEENAN-BOLGER: It's funny.
I don't know why I play kids.
I really don't.
I mean, it was certainly not
anything I set out to do,
but it has been a
theme in my career.
And there was a point when I
was like, I'm done with this.
I don't want to do it anymore.
And then things kept
coming up, where
I was like, oh, that's a
really, really great part.
Yeah.
I said to Gideon once.
I was like, it
feels like asking--
I don't know if you guys know
who Kelli O'Hara is, but she's
this glorious soprano--
like, why do you keep playing
these amazing ingnues.
And it's like, there is
something inside of her,
the gifts that she was given,
which are this glorious voice,
that she just knows what to do.
And the only thing
I can liken it to
is that there is
something inside of me
that knows what to do.
And obviously, I really hope
this is the last kid I play,
but I bet it's not.
I mean, there's a good
chance that it's not,
that I'm going to do it
again, and that will be fine.
It's just something in my
career that has followed me.
And I think, probably,
your body of work
always influences
where I am now.
And I'm sure there is a part
of Olive, to a part of Molly,
to a part of Laura in
"The Glass Menagerie."
You bring it all with you.
So I think they're not
completely separate entities.
But this is--
I mean, I don't want to pick
favorites, but Scott Finch,
come on.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Aaron.
This is a question for you.
First of all, I grew up
watching "The West Wing"
when I was seven.
It really means a lot to me,
so I really appreciate it.
My question is--
AARON SORKIN: Seven?
BEN FRIED: It's a young company.
AUDIENCE: It means a lot
to my family as well.
They were older than
seven when it was on.
My question is, do
you have any advice
for managing the
creative process,
specifically hitting deadlines
and what to keep in mind when
working against that?
AARON SORKIN: Yeah.
I'm probably the worst person
to get advice from on that.
When you're writing a play,
when you're writing a movie,
and it's not going well,
you're not writing well,
you can call whoever
is waiting for it,
the producer, the studio, the
director, and you can say,
hey, I've kind of
run into a snow bank.
I know I said I'd deliver
the first draft in June.
It'll probably be
more like September,
or that kind of thing.
In television,
you can't do that.
You have hard deadlines
because of the air dates, which
means that you
have to write, even
when you're not writing well.
And that's a really
tough pill to swallow.
And then you have to
take that and put it
on the table for the
cast, for the table read,
and that's really
difficult. And then
you have to point
a camera at it.
Did you ask me about
managing anxiety?
Because I'm feeling anxiety.
Listen, people ask me
if I get writer's block.
Writer's block is
my default position.
I have periodic bursts
of, hey, I have an idea,
a writable idea.
But the rest of the time,
I'm climbing the walls.
I love writing.
I hate not writing.
I hate what I'm supposed
to be writing and I can't.
It drives me out of my mind.
I'm making it
worse, your anxiety?
AUDIENCE: I think it's
already much better.
AARON SORKIN: OK.
I have no advice.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AARON SORKIN: Sure.
BEN FRIED: On that
note, I'm sorry,
I'm told we are out of time.
Thank you so much.
AARON SORKIN: Thank
you very much.
BEN FRIED: Celia, Gideon,
Aaron, Gbenga, and Jeff.
[APPLAUSE]